[Music]
let's face it the foundation of any show
like mine are the interns they do a lot
of hard work and they do it for free and
I'm here with some of our finest interns
Danielle Danielle Julia Julia Evan Evan
pencil guy yeah
glasses woman what surprised you when
you first saw me saw me for the first
time what was the thing that surprised
you most Evan yes sir what did you won't
surprise you most about me how fast you
are pencil guy yeah first couple times I
saw you behind the scenes you were
wearing these this vest sort of like not
really a jacket but a vest I was really
surprised to see that those are still in
yeah do you wait glasses woman next to
pencil guy yes what surprised you when
you first saw me I was surprised at how
much thought and care went into what
happened during the show it shocked you
that there was a rehearsal process yeah
and then I put any thought into it
in the nicest way possible sure you
could say that after any sentence
I'd like to murder you in the nicest way
possible
by the way Joe you'll replace these as
we go with this and you'd be completely
honest is this your favorite late night
show and be honest uh you are my
favorite personality-wise late night
show was my favorite show and it's hard
to say I don't really have a favorite I
[Applause]
know how to do it
do you guys have complaints about this
job there's not too much going on in
here so the other day I organized the
sugar packets yeah they're all their own
kind of ask you right now but I mean
they were so you show me what you did
um well I went through and I stacked
them all neatly like so they weren't
looking like they're just thrown in
there like CDs okay just make them more
accessible just have this
there's medication for what you have
Aven yes sir
you know I remember Evan not just the
name tag no that's helping Evans
enthusiasm feeds me I also got your
lunch you got my lunch today yeah I
didn't eat lunch today
oh well how did you get my lunch if I
didn't eat lunch today they told me to
go get the boss man's lunch who told you
to get Conan's lunch give me a name Nick
Nick
who's Nick what's Nick what's in it
Evon mmm was told today to go get
Conan's lunch absolutely I did that but
Conan didn't eat lunch
Conan's didn't even order lunch I spoke
with Sona so we've been into a little
bit of a snafu here Evan said hey I got
your lunch today I said that's not
possible
I didn't order lunch today sometimes in
order to get things done quickly for me
I might use your name to like light a
fire please say it I once went to a bar
and drank too much and couldn't drive
home so I sent interns the next day this
was a long time ago to pick the car up
and I may have said that I needed them
there's people out there that think
Conan O'Brien had too much to drink and
couldn't get his car what rumors have
you heard about me anybody have a good
rumor you heard about me you we're awake
did you actually hear that yeah you
heard that Ike we're gonna win yeah
would you mind quickly just proving to
people that it's not awake yeah
go like get in there don't be afraid and
Paul what are you getting yeah but you
can you can you save it with great
certainty what are you looking for
they're not
it goes back instantly okay you guys go
to parties you're young other people
meet you and you talk maybe about what
you do and I just like to hear what you
might say hey how's it going okay yeah
good I'm Brad to name Julia that's a
cool name thank you yeah what are you
drinking thank you some gin and juice
when you drink
yeah oh you seem to drink a lot okay so
um just curious like what do you do I
work for Conan Conan O'Brien Conan
O'Brien oh my god you don't get to meet
him though right you see him what's he
like he's really cool would you tell me
about it what's what's it like to work
for common he's really tall yeah really
long stride okay so he's tall he's a
long stride very funny
okay that's the third thing is he's very
tall
this guy was blown away that you know
koenig no no when you were like he's
very tall and he has a long stride
[Music]
you're describing an ostrich you guys
see what the problem was there what did
she do wrong yeah yeah what do you do uh
my intern at the Conan O'Brien show in
does she wear a wig he does not wear
away the full head of hair
lucious how do you know he doesn't worry
I didn't touch you touched his hair
did he ask you to he actually invited me
to he sounds like a pervert I'm calling
the police
please end of the line
hey hey what's goin goin are you guy or
girl right now
Oh God oh hey who's that do it say hello
to the pencils who do you like a nerd or
something no I just sometimes I need to
write things down dickyvicky take you
did he did I'm about to beat you up I
beat the crap out of you unless you can
impress me with where you work honey no
all gasp why are you touching me
and you talk I have enjoyed getting to
know you and so if you guys are okay
with it I'd like to right now take you
all out to dinner would you like to go
to dinner with me get dinner with me
[Applause]
they are the best